Dear Lord, look at this guy.
The sculpted miracle of
a man is Bryan Johnson,
the very moneyed former owner of Venmo
who literally looks
younger every passing day.
I consider myself to be
a professional rejuvenation athlete.
The speed at which I'm aging
is less than a 10 year old.
I spend millions of dollars a year.
I do over a hundred
therapies in any given day.
What Bryan really wants is to be 18 again,
and of course, so do I.
We just seem to be going about
it in very different ways.
I try to get perfect sleep.
I eat 70 pounds of vegetables.
I work out an hour a day.
The science is still unclear
as to which of us will hit
the fountain of youth first,
but the former Utahan thinks
part of the answer lies
within his newly claimed city.
I love this place.
When I was looking for where to live next
I mapped out a few big cities in the US.
And I wanted to find something
where you could do and say
and be anything you wanted.
And people a lot of times
think about LA Hollywood first.
I think most people will be surprised
that there's like all this
other stuff going on here.
There's this huge invisible world.
Los Angeles first called
to me when I was 18.
I arrived here at the
spectacular Pomona College
where I was a philosophy major.
Philosophy major.
I am often asked, what
does a philosophy major do?
Well, I do the only thing I can do,
which is show you people that can do.
LA's thing has always been
that anything is possible here.
Away from Hollywood fame,
it's a city rich with car culture,
aerospace dreams and industrial factories.
This is the LA that I love.
And while you may not know it,
LA is in the midst of turning into
the most interesting
manufacturing hub in the world.
To begin our journey into
this metallic underworld,
let me show you Walden Speed Shop
and its proprietor Bobby Walden.
He's part of LA's manufacturing legacy.
He's been in the metal
shaping industry for 35 years,
building and fixing vintage
car parts the old school way,
by hand.
Metal shaping is an extremely old craft
but the thing holds true
even from hundreds of years ago to now,
there's only three things
you can do to metal
and that's shrink it, and
stretch, it and form it,
which is kind of folding.
Other than that, there's
really no new technology.
I really cut my teeth
making Harley Davidson
body parts from scratch.
And then the hot rods
started working on those
and chopping tops and building
panels and fixing rust
and then started building pieces of bodies
and eventually became building
an entire body from scratch.
If you're going to do what Bobby does,
Southern California is the place to do it.
The cool thing about
Southern California first off
is the weather.
Back in the forties after World
War II, the guys came back.
Now these guys are kids still.
And they have lived a life and seen things
that we can't even imagine today.
And they come back, they're
alive, they're vibrant
and they want thrills, right?
The first thing is they
start with the cars.
They were cruising everywhere
and then they were probably
10 drag strips around here.
You could drag race every day of the week
except for like Tuesday and Wednesday.
It was 50 Mercurys and
the crazy custom cars.
Because of the aerospace
industry that was out here,
there was a lot of available material
that you couldn't get
anywhere else in the country.
The cars kept progressing
and getting better and better
and better and better, you know.
Los Angeles at one time,
there were thousands of shops
that did pattern making,
small casting shops.
And all these artisans,
unbelievably gifted and
talented men and women.
But as time evolved
and manufacturing started
being sent overseas
and automation came into play,
then these skills and
these jobs and these shops
got swallowed up and lost.
If the trade or the skill
isn't taught and perpetuated forward,
then we go back, we regress.
Bobby offered to show me
every twist, bang and clang
that goes into making a simple metal bowl.
If we're going to make a bowl,
obviously this thing has to curl up.
So it has to be shrunk.
He is a patient teacher.
But it's real simple.
That gives you a tuck.
So you kind of just
twisting back and forth.
Yep, twist it like that,
and then go back the other way.
Is this a disaster?
No such thing.
All right, perfect.
Looks good. Serious.
And now you go back in here
and you flatten these pooches out.
Okay.
This isn't a glamorous thing that I do.
It's hard work.
It's cold in the winter
and it's hot in the summer
and it's loud all the time.
And when you go home at the
end of the day you are tired.
If only we had a robot
that could pick up some of that slack.
If you had a robot to pick
up the slack, you know,
and something you could
like scan something
and it could memorize it,
keep the dimensions and all that stuff.
Maybe one day.
Meanwhile, across town that very same day,
I am told that a group of robots
is sometimes known as a colony.
And this colony of robots
belongs to Machina Labs
and it's co-founder and CEO, Ed Mehr.
These are the sheet metal
bending ultramodern successors
to folks like Bobby Walden.
Sheet metal is the biggest
metal processing sector
out of all the metal processing.
You pretty much, most of
the parts you see day to day
are sheet metal parts.
You're driving in a freeway,
you're kind of in the CF sheet metal,
or you're sitting in an airplane,
it's basically a sheet metal canon.
They don't really have
a very agile solution
to make these parts.
They all basically have
to build a factory for it
before you can get your
first batch of parts.
Yeah.
Factories that produce large metal parts,
like car doors or airplane wings,
can be the size of a football
field and three stories high,
huge, very intricate and
not at all adaptable.
This is just a common
problem manufacturing
that a lot of factories
are specifically built
for the products they're
trying to manufacture.
And the moment you want
to change your design,
you want to change your material,
you have to almost build another factory.
So what we're trying
to do at Machina really
is can we have that overarching automation
that is not process specific.
It's a platform that allows the robot
to go pick up the right tool
and apply it to the material
so they can get the right part,
the same way a craftsman or blacksmith
used to do these parts.
These bots have the skills
to make fancy new shapes and old ones
that are too challenging for
other companies to make today.
I know a lot of the stuff you work on
is kind of top secret.
Can we talk about all these things?
Yeah.
This one's an interesting one.
It's actually a composite
mold for a drone wing.
So they basically lay up
composite on top of this
and then they put it in a vacuum
bag and put it in a furnace
and then they get a
composite part out of it.
Is this your donut operation?
Yeah, I know.
Giant donut.
This is actually like,
Toroidal Tanks is one of the
most good designs for like,
you know, satellites tanks.
Okay, like a fuel tank or-
Fuel tanks.
Okay.
One of the challenges with these
is that it's very hard to manufacture.
Back in the sixties actually,
NASA used to make these things
and they mostly relied on basically
talented individuals. - People
we've like lost the knowledge-
NASA knowledge.
And so we're kind of working with NASA
to revive some of these as well.
But even if you're not NASA,
just a regular Joe or Jane metal fanatic,
you too can hire a pair of
these robots to do your bidding.
This is your mocking a starter
pack if you're a customer.
You get two robots and you get
this platform in the center
that holds the metal sheets
that costs you about $2.5
million to get going.
And then it's about learning this process
of orchestrating the robots
using Machina software
and getting going with these things.
To truly put these robots to the test,
I had what's known in LA as
the engineer's skin peel.
This is step one of having
your face built by a robot
is to get this mug scanned
with a laser that's
also mounted on a robot.
It's not super dangerous.
It's a class two laser.
It's like one level above a laser pointer.
Probably want to close
your eyes when we do this?
Ready?
Ready.
Alright.
Please tell it to be gentle.
Alright. Eyes closed.
3, 2, 1. Here we go.
After the laser, well, lasered my face,
the resulting 3D file was sent
to these two fine workers.
They set about making metal me,
each with its own clearly defined role.
At each point in time is
basically one robot is forming,
and the other robot we
call like a support robot.
Okay.
So while one robot puts all its effort
into deforming the sheet of metal,
the other robot makes
sure that deformation
is only happening where they want it to.
In this case, on the indent,
increasingly looking like someone I know.
It's just like me.
Good job, robot. Good job.
And the robot generated wonders
didn't and there.
So Ashlee, we made a little piece for you.
Kind of take as a souvenir from LA.
Yeah, it was awesome.
I feel like the flavor
flavor of robot machinery.
Yeah, it looks good on you.
That is awesome man. Thank you.
I feel I've made it.
Admiring my glorious metal bounty,
I couldn't help but wonder,
what is it about LA that makes
such innovation possible?
Every time I come to LA,
it's this new take on manufacturing
and this way a lot of it
comes out of aerospace.
But to me it feels like
if there is a manufacturing
revolution taking place
where all this stuff works
and we make some kind of
step change to a new age,
it feels like LA is somehow ended up
as the epicenter of that.
Is this like coincidence
or this had to be here?
No, I agree with you.
And honestly like partially
it's because of SpaceX.
It's hard to talk about
LA's manufacturing scene
without acknowledging
the Elon in the room.
Like just about everyone
here doing sci-fi building,
Ed used to work at SpaceX,
the aerospace giant located on
the outskirts of Los Angeles.
I think one thing Elon did
for the folks who went to SpaceX was like
he really broke that fear
of testing with hardware.
It was like, well why
don't we just make hardware
the same way you make software?
Yeah.
Like why don't you just test it
and you know, every two
months, three months
try something else.
And a lot of folks who
were exposed to that,
I think got a little
bit of confidence there.
It was like, okay, yeah, no,
I can put together a
facility with the 22 robots
and just figure this out.
Yeah.
Next stop, another former SpaceX-er
taking manufacturing to the stars.
When I was sitting at
SpaceX working on the plan
for how we're going to colonize Mars,
my brain kept coming back
to over and over again,
how are we going to make things on Mars?
We're not going to ship
billet and machine it on Mars.
We'll want to make it in
situ while we're there.
That also kind of planted the seed for me
to kind of go into the 3D printing.
Erik Palitsch, co-founder
and CEO of Freeform
wants to make building size 3D printers
with conveyor belts and assembly lines.
And to do that, they got to
have a crap ton of lasers
and the digital brains
to coordinate them all.
He's working on a prototype.
Alright, so this is the machine.
This is it.
Lovingly call it golden eye.
Yeah, 'cause of the lasers.
Yes, because of the lasers.
The lasers are what make
metal 3D printing possible,
heating up a metallic powder
and welding each new layer
to the previous layer.
We have more lasers on a
system that's running right now
while we're talking than
anyone in the world.
Okay, let's have a look.
I just-
Let me get you a little-
Can I have a stool please?
My viewing stool.
The viewing stool, yeah.
Yeah, it is crazy.
You could just see all the
lasers got to go at once right?
Yeah, all 18 should be going right now.
It looks like something
engineered by a super villain
to kill a secret agent all too slowly.
But this machine represents
a huge breakthrough for 3D printing.
It's much faster, much cheaper
and much more precise
than what has come before.
It possibly gets 3D printing close
to being mass manufacturing technology.
There has been this belief for many years
that the only way to go faster
is to trade trade quality.
The real problem is that
the machines today are,
for lack of a better word, are dumb.
You pre-program instructions
and then you tell the
machine to go do that.
You just iterate on it
until you get it right
and then don't change it.
What a shame for a technology
that shouldn't care
what the part is coming off the machine.
Right.
I mean the whole thing is about
creativity and imagination.
Exactly.
Sort of limitlessness.
Freeform un-dumbs these contraptions
by collecting information
on what the machine did
and feeding that into a neural network
that can then learn how
to do it better next time,
a process that requires an
unholy amount of information.
It's actually kind of crazy,
the amount of data we move here
is like rivals like Netflix,
you know, like the
sheer magnitude of data.
All that data means Freeform
can make insanely complex
designs out of robust metal,
and eventually rocket engines, car parts
and whatever it is they make on Mars.
At this point in my journey
through Los Angeles,
I was feeling that like any
other TV host in Hollywood,
I needed a useless award for myself.
So I had Erik print one up.
For exploring manufacturing in Los Angeles
and doing such an amazing job,
I present to you the Worldy.
Thank you so much.
This is glorious.
What's it made out of?
Metal.
That's incredible.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
Seeing what marvels can be accomplished
without the touch of a human hand,
I couldn't help but think of
the Bobby Waldens of the world.
The nerd in me just likes
the machines themselves
and seeing what comes out of them.
But like none of this
stuff comes with many jobs.
So there is this like
kind of hollow feeling
that accompanies this, even
if it's a huge success.
We're trying to take the human
out of the loop of the process itself
'cause humans aren't good at that.
But we're going to need lots of people
to build these factories.
We're going to need people
to maintain these factories.
Computers cannot substitute
for human creativity.
That's what we should be
training people to do,
to like deploy these precision robotics
and maintain these precision robotics,
you know, not like vacuum
powder off a plate, you know.
Come on buddy. Here we go.
Let's go home.
Carrying around all this metal
was becoming a real drag.
So I skipped across town
for something a bit lighter,
sugar at a company that's invented
a whole new way of making sweet treats.
Super proud of this.
This is the current 3D printer,
we designed and built it from scratch.
You can see like it looks like
a kind of commercial kitchen equipment.
But it also contains all of the processes
that we're familiar with with 3D printing.
It manages this dry powder,
which is starch and sugar.
And then we've got a print head over here
which moves across and
actually prints the object.
These 3D printers can go
into any commercial kitchen
in the US and even across the globe.
Very cool. And I could just eat it?
Yeah.
I don't recommend eating
that all in one sitting.
But yes, everything is edible,
completely edible.
Flying off the walls.
For the taste test.
So we have a nice assortment
of different things.
Chef Jonathan walked me through the menu.
We have dealer's choice here.
I got some chocolate covered sushi,
or maybe something a little
more refreshing, like our lime.
Like a skull.
Skull.
Just your classic skull.
Just your classic experience skull.
Hmm. Oh yeah, you could taste the lime.
Yeah.
It's sweet, but it's not as sweet
as I kind of thought it was going to be.
It's like more meringue like in texture.
That is what I was looking for.
It's like a meringue.
But Sugar Lab isn't limited to sugar.
As long as the food can
be dehydrated into powder,
the team can print it.
Think matcha, think kimchi,
think sparkly stuff.
We do a lot of drink drops dissolvables
that we put in our
cocktails, wine, champagnes.
So you just plunk it?
Oh, it's cool. You get the
color and you get the fizz.
Maybe give it a little stir.
Can I taste?
Yeah.
Is it safe to drink this much glitter?
Yeah. Yeah.
It's totally food safe edible glitter.
But there was more.
We have a strawberry covered chocolate.
And more.
Here we got our everlasting gobstopper.
A cranberry Frankenstein.
One of our nineties bon bon shells.
A matcha Buddha for you.
Hazy IPA ganache.
Bon Bon or glitter salt.
They're happy little pencil bon bon.
You got our fun little octopus there.
Your favorite boat drink drops.
It sparkles.
The green tea bon bon.
That's really good.
I don't recommend eating that.
Don't recommend eating those.
The thing about LA, man, is
that the ideas are so big.
You can do anything here.
You can print things out of sugar.
You can buy Twitter
with your spare change.
You can mine asteroids.
You can go to Mars.
Sugar Ashlee is right.
In this city, the galaxy
is truly your oyster.
But how do you get there?
Welcome to LA Traffic.
Well, that's next time.